started
[Applause]
[Music]
Penn Badgley channeling Elaine in his
latest viral tick tock
and totally nailing the iconic Seinfeld
dance in front of who else Elaine
herself Julia Louis-Dreyfus
pen totally Nails the characters
questionable moves complete with
exaggerated kicks spins and enthusiastic
arm movements have you ever seen Elaine
dance
Elaine dance
it's more like a full body dry heave set
the music
in The Tick Tock Julia doesn't appear
amused by Penn's parody but she knows
it's all in good fun on an episode of
his podcast pod crushed she opened up to
the U star about when she realized the
90s sitcom was such a cultural
phenomenon when we're doing the finale
there were people on the other side with
long lenses trying to take pictures and
I remember thinking seriously wow I
guess this is really a big deal but to
see the impact in that moment that's
when it kind of first struck me that
that this was maybe ginormous as for
Penn he's becoming quite the social
media star we are loving all of your
tick tock
all the dancing I mean it's nice to have
fun on social media for the time being
otherwise I'm pretty quiet on there yeah
even with just a handful of videos pens
got more than three and a half million
Tick Tock followers and more than 27
million likes if you look at my kind of
stats I'm not even on it that much my
batting average is like
High the 34 year old joined the app out
of the blue last October and his first
post a slam dunk after he recreated part
of Taylor Swift's anti-hero music video
[Music]
that he took on the Meghan Trainor made
you look dance and nailed it
[Music]
last year Vogue magazine dubbed him the
Lord of The Tick Tock dance and he has
kept up the momentum
[Music]
on a paper chase
but one dance we're dying to see him try
you co-star Jenna Ortega's iconic
Wednesday dance
[Music]
I think we need a Joe and Ellie reunion
so you and Jenna Ortega admit she's too
big now I can't get Jenna seriously
um although I do love Jenna shout out to
Jenna until then we'll just enjoy Penn's
sweet moves we
[Music]
do